In the sense that everyone understands
what it is and there's no one who's
hasn't been touched in some way.
A mother,
a daughter,
a sister,
a friend.
We're not starting with,
let me tell you what breast cancer is.
Everyone knows about it.
It's come out of the closet.
There's no stigma.
It's very different from what it was
when Evelyn started.
And I think everyone wants to be
supportive either because they've had a
personal experience or almost for an
insurance policy.
If I do support it,
then maybe I won't have that personal
experience.
So it's an easy subject to broach with
people and people are incredibly
responsive.
Mostly
the money that we have raised,
we have waste in the United States
though.
We have disbursed it internationally.
So we have added on grantees now in
Canada,
France,
Belgium,
Spain,
the UK,
Italy,
the Middle East and Latin America.
For the most part,
we're still deriving the bulk of our
money in the United States.
Um,
though we've had some wonderful help
from companies and,
and estee lauder up in Canada.
Um,
and some programs in the UK for the most
part,
the money has been derived here because
the tax incentives for philanthropy that
existed in u s don't exist elsewhere.
No.
You know,
the amount of money is,
has,
has at the very best stayed flat.
And if you factor in inflation,
it's decreased.
The whole NCI budget for cancer is 5
billion,
which may sound like a lot,
but when you look at what the tobacco
industry spends about 15 billion
advertising cigarettes to teenagers or
the pet food industry spends about 14
billion advertising pet food.
Um,
it's a small drop in the bucket in all
about 11 billion is spent on cancer
research across the NCI,
the National Cancer Institute,
pharmaceuticals and private
organizations like the Breast Cancer
Research Foundation.
So it's not a lot of money in the
federal budget has certainly diminished,
if anything.
And,
and the pity is that there has never
been a moment in time when knowledge,
scientific knowledge is advancing at
such a rapid clip.
It's a hungry animal.
So that if you could feed it,
the answers will come more.
Click quickly.
Dr. Larry Norton at Memorial Sloan
Kettering Cancer Center,
who is our scientific advisor and has
been since the inception of the
foundation,
says truly the only thing that stands
between today and it is money.
Tough question.
I don't what inspires the herb.
Kent,
if I knew the answer,
I'd be,
I'd be very smart.
I don't what inspires the government.
Um,
but obviously there have been other
calls on the,
the federal dollar as you know,
um,
the war and other things.
And one can only hope that under new
leadership there might be an enrichment
of the federal coffers.
Because right now if you are a
researcher,
you spent half the year writing a
federal grant and you have only a slim
percentage of chance that that will get
funded.
Only 8% of approved grants actually get
And the pity is then there's a brain
drain.
People are actually leaving the field in
droves.
They get this tremendous education.
They have the vision,
they have the drive.
But if they can't get the dollars to
move their research forward,
they can't pursue what they've been
trained to do.
We try to put dollars private dollars in
the hands of researchers who have new
ideas often to help them get the base
data that will make them competitor for
the limited federal dollars.
It's like a chicken and egg.
You can't compete for the dollars until
you have the data.
You almost have to finish your research
or know the answer before you can start.
So an organization like ours plays a
critical function,
often teen people up to compete for the
limited dollars and often moving
research forward that might otherwise
language for decades can.
At the end of the day,
Keith was wives
[inaudible]
my tin cuff.
And where you and where you contribute?
Well first of all,
because I know we're on the side of the
angels,
I know we're doing good.
I know we're making a difference.
Um,
I'm not asking for myself.
People always say to me,
what's the key to being a good
fundraiser?
It's being able to ask in a way that
people can say no,
and the doors open for you to come back.
It's asking in a collaborative fashion.
Um,
and so how has our success come about?
We're very attentive to retaining our
donors,
cultivating our donors,
stewarding rs owners,
and growing the average gift size and
was equally as [inaudible] in acquiring
new donors.
And if you do both and you don't have a
drain at one side and you're new and,
and you never grow because your new one
simply replace.
We're very dedicated across the board.
I like asking for money,
not for myself,
but this is for a good cause.
I like doing,
it fires me up.
And Evelyn Lauder,
who is the founder and chairman of the
foundation,
is as,
as dog in and dedicated as I am.
She's also smart,
appreciative,
and a wonderful colleague.
So it's very motivational when you work
for somebody whose heart and soul into
this with you and a partner,
a true partner.
And we do it together with zeal and with
success in your job.
[inaudible].